opening
yes hello everybody
hello it's Friday and you know what that
means time to shoot Brian kill meat out
of a cannon
not really let's just welcome tonight's
guests
he can't say anything nice about
somebody she'll say it anyway co-host of
the bottom line on Fox Business Gigan
McDowell
he might be Canadian but he's not just
blowing smoke entrepreneur and Sharkey
host Kevin O'Leary
he Yanks more cranks than Stormy Daniels
comedian Jim Florentine
and finally she's always scathing but
rarely bathing Fox News contributor
captive
all right
all right thank you for the Applause
it's meant for me
now before we get to some news stories
it is Friday so let's do this
Greg's leftovers
yep it's leftovers where I read the
jokes we didn't use this week and as
always it's my first time reading them
so if they suck don't blame me
blame the writer we cover in red ants
after the show
here we go smoke from Canadian wildfires
created hazy skies and unhealthy air
quality in New York City this week
visibility in Times Square was so bad
New Yorkers had to urinate by feel
[Music]
in New York for 24 hours it's like
smoking six cigarettes whereas my aunt
Edna calls it breakfast
they even have stock photos for really
old people
why did you look at me no I was just
thinking about
I was thinking that Joe Biden would be a
great stock photo for like that you know
what I mean okay speaking of fire
earlier this week fire crews in New
Jersey completely contained two major
forest fires that caused evacuations but
residents were heartbroken when they
were told they could return to their
homes
that's so funny
Pete Davidson and Peta are feuding after
the group called him out for buying a
puppy from a pet store of course they
already hated him anyway because he
slings a lot of meat
for you kids at home it's best not to
know what that means
Red Sox pitcher Matt demote pitched
Thursday which was just under two years
to the day since he posted a tweet that
said homosexuals will go to hell when
asked about the Tweet demode said I
wasn't referring to gay people I was
obviously referring to New York Yankee
fans
[Applause]
in a new interview Arnold Schwarzenegger
said he believes that heaven is just a
fantasy he didn't elaborate if it's a
bad fantasy like Conan the Destroyer or
a good fantasy like banging your maid
earlier this week former New Jersey
Governor Chris Christie announced that
he will be running for president in
2024.
yeah I know it's good that he's running
after the announcement which was made at
a campaign event in New Hampshire he got
a five-minute Standing Ovation and that
was just from the caterers
oh
earlier this week former VP Mike Pence
also announced his run for president so
people who thought they heard the last
from Mike Pence will have to wait for
his announcement that he's dropping out
poor guy last week the California
Highway Patrol got into a high-speed
chase with a Toyota Prius
I know who needs a punch line
unfortunately the the Prius got away
because the police car got too far ahead
Apple announced this week that the new
iPhone update will stop auto correcting
swear words which is great news for the
millions of fox viewers who sent texts
to Jesse Waters
and finally a bar in Australia has
apologized after offering free drinks
based on bra size
apparently the promotion went South
after a recent Patron nearly caused them
to declare bankruptcy
had to work
most famous
Canadian besides you Kevin now on to
some news they want to burn one at the
stake while the other is barely awake is
Biden's justice system unequal as his
underpants are mostly fecal
I know disgusting I feel the same way
I'm going to write a letter to this show
within the span of just two hours
yesterday big news broke for former
president Trump and fake President Biden
after 5 p.m Fox digital reported Biden
scored a 5 million dollar Ukrainian
payday Democrats say it's misleading
because candy bars cost more there
[Laughter]
even that one hurt me
because you know paydays
it's a candy bar
an FBI document reportedly details how
an executive at Hunter's Oil Company
paid him the alleged bribe which
explains how Joe is able to afford
depends in bulk
here's how Joe responded the library
allocation Congresswoman Nancy May says
evidence and FBI file that he sold out
the country in response to the
Congressional Republicans where's the
money I'm joking Mr President
[Music]
yes a bunch of malarkey Malarkey of
course is Joe's way of showing he's hip
with the kids
and where's the money good question
maybe has nine of your relatives you
also receive foreign income
you know I'd say follow the money but I
fear I would end up inside Hunter's
rectum
[Laughter]
yeah
Hannity and I fought over that joke
so right after that Biden news
conveniently just two hours later Trump
gets indicted for the thousandth time
the Biden Administration is calling it
operation change to the subject
he's facing several federal charges
seven federal charges in a classified
documents probe a defiant Trump called
it election interference at the highest
level I wonder if he thinks our country
is going to hell our country is going to
hell and they come after Donald Trump
weaponizing the justice department
weaponizing the FBI we can't let this
continue to go on because it's ripping
our country to shreds I would agree but
I don't want to be called a terrorist or
get audited so how is Trump handling the
news otherwise
with a round of golf at his Sumptuous
Bedminster Golf Club
look at all those caddies holy crap Mr
President next time shoot me an invite
so it's a tale of two presidents and two
different treatments one gets persecuted
for alleged process violations and
another gets ignored for influence
peddling potentially bribery and lacking
a functioning brain
what's Joe got to say
[Music]
come on
what is it today uh crimes all right
look doesn't matter what Joe did all
right because you always remember orange
man bad Joe might have done a little bad
orange man did more bad that's all you
remember five million here five million
there give me a break
give me a break break me off a piece of
that Ukraine cash no no don't break me
off I mean what I'm saying is I didn't I
didn't do any of that oh hell everybody
knows what I did but no
Mean Tweets
okay again
uh there's some uh process charges and
some Espionage
charges uh what do you make of all this
well I'll focus on Biden because if
Biden is
it kind of looks like he's sick in his
justice department on his chief
political rival is it too much to ask
did he actually then act like a
tyrannical despot if he's going to use
the powers of his office to go after a
political opponent like instead we get
this like
smirking clumsy cone liquor it yeah like
you think all the ice cream he's eating
at least he would look like Kim Jong-un
like a refrigerator made a pudding yeah
and or like he needs to dawn like a
putinian dictator stance oh I have a
demonic laugh
instead he's coughing off a dime
shuffling around like he's wearing
bedroom shoes and you look at him and go
man needs some Fosamax doesn't look like
that he would do what we think he did
too that's why he got elected this is
potentially even more divisive than
anything he's done before Kevin what do
you make of this so just to set the
table there's never been a president
that's been indicted before not twice
not once yeah and you have to murder
somebody to have this happen because
presidents get passes because it's not
in the public interest to go back and
chop the office to pieces yeah this is a
different ballgame I love presidential
politics I absolutely love this stuff
and it's it's better than football
my question because I'm a follow the
money guy is what does this do for
fundraising now 20 years ago it would
really matter what Wall Street thinks
because the way these presidential guys
would go is they'd come up to Boston and
up to New York and say look you got to
give my campaign X dollars out of your
firm The Firm didn't do it but the
partners would they made sure they gave
the dams the same amount they gave red
Reds and blue are equal that's how it
worked and then then your investors call
you up say hey are you supporting one
part of the other you say no right in
the middle yeah it doesn't matter as
much anymore the Wall Street dudes don't
matter because most of the money is
raised online 20 bucks at a time so am I
thinking on this just you know in the
debate we're having this morning about
it this is going to motivate people so
much I don't care whether you're on the
Biden you know potential subpoena deal
or you're Trump getting your 15th
indictment or whatever it is I stopped
counting this gets people really
motivated yeah so I bet you that cash is
coming in like crazy and Wall Street
doesn't matter anymore because the Wall
Street guys the ones I talked to this
morning you're saying what treason whoa
yeah not so easy to work with right
exactly it's it says I think I think
you're right I think there's like they
were hoping to exhaust Trump supporters
Jim but I think they've actually
energized them because it fulfills
everything Trump says about being
persecuted being a Target right yeah
absolutely I mean look it's just a
coincidence I think that they both came
down on the same day yeah as soon as
they announced the Biden stuff the
bribery stuff all of a sudden the Trump
stuff came two hours later they couldn't
have done it today I had to do it was
just a weird coincidence I know yeah but
I mean you got to think that Biden with
the bribery and then Trump with this
going on and they're both leading
candidates in their in their parties
like the Santos has got to be like I got
to go rob a bank
so my poll numbers go off
do you realize that good 2024 on the
presidential debate stage both guys
could be wearing ankle bracelets it
could possibly happen it's possible
the guy with the guy with the most
indictments wins I mean it could be that
way how many indictments does it take to
win exactly that's true what Trump's in
the lead right now but Biden could be
coming up soon exactly I think we've
redefined the uh the presidential
politics I'm all for it because Trump's
way ahead in the polls and indictments
right now but you never know Biden could
come and pull it out he could pull it
out well Hunter could anyway
he never pulls out Hunter yes he should
have pulled out once
foreign
I'm sorry about that we have we have
women here disgusting so cat
um you know uh
but Democrats
Democrats were saying if if nothing's
done at the debt ceiling there will be
violence in the streets they would say
there's gonna be violence or the Supreme
Court go to the story but then they do
stuff like this which is like actually
could really inflame a bunch of Voters
because really when they're going after
Trump they're going after the voters
he's just kind of a proxy in a way well
I mean they're going after Trump and I I
also think when you say things have
changed in terms of like indictments Are
Everything Has Changed right uh I mean
the Espionage Act charges I I think the
Espionage Act is bad it has historically
been can be used and has historically
been used to stifle dissent in this
country and
we're now at a point where Republicans
are going to like me for saying that
which I did not see coming
um whenever I said about Julian Assange
for example people would like say you're
a traitor go to hell you and stuff
like that
um that was from Brett Bear yeah right
right uh no Brett's cool now he had me
on once and I did so well that I'm sure
I'll be guest hosting at any time
um but it's everything all the rules
that are supposed to exist they don't
anymore and I think that at this point a
lot of people probably have corruption
and Scandal fatigue because it is just
like dueling scandals and it's usually
not in the same day but that was a wild
ride I think they are hoping to exhaust
the Maga but it's impossible because
it's actually they're mistaking the
exhaust mistaking gasoline for
exhaustion they're just filling the tank
the more you go after Trump he just gets
more energy we're not finished with
indictment test we have the Atlanta
voting stuff right and so by then it's
not even going to be news yeah because I
think everybody's forgotten that Trump
got impeached too yeah that's old boring
news yes new indictments I mean look
it's serious stuff but okay more
indictments I mean it's it's very very
weird it is why do you think that there
are so many Republican candidates
running for the nomination
but they just
clearly they're all trying to be good
guys and gals but some of them are
clearly thinking Trump's not going to be
on the field yeah why else would they be
jumping in right Chris Christie please
yeah and when he jumps in
when he jumps in oh man Cannonball all
right hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else